[Music]
[Applause]
you were
[Music]
in software
anaya
world work and save lives
[Music]
and
since the morning played and it's at
night at night play in art
because you like them  all the trees
because there is no noise simón store of
rules it's already happened everywhere I go
there and here from here to there and
here
in my family there are 11 people the oldest
is my father pedro lópez he is 47 years old and
when did you start in the caravan
yes also
that was the main challenge the main challenge
and tofollow her
on the third day I could no longer
walk because she came my feet
gave me sores
and a father could hardly walk for
example as a mobile
as they brought her well fixing
the chair  wheels I work on it boy
from tapachula
frei de comayagua life numbering capital
sun land a country currently usually
arrives in the united states
the first time they deported me
and in the second time
my parts were going to be lost again I did it
with the purpose of getting ahead
in this
time 16 years ago I go over the building
now I try to try
again but don't say that you see that I don't
give up
[Music]
I bring my family because I
mean if my family had gone but  I do
n't bring it because those who are really
behind the scenes because I have problems
in my country
I had problems in the country with the
gangs they wanted to attack my family
so that's why he transmits them to me
[Music]
what is a caravan that was visualized that
there are many children  girls and adolescents
was one of the slowest caravans we
have seen because they have gone
too slowly this is the first
caravan there were approximately 1,300
migrants later another
caravan of Cubans who arrived
there was added and those Cubans are like a thousand because
we currently have  in mapastepec it is the
first caravan led by the
cuban doctor mike we are going to do our best we go
like this to the kilo
well we do there too and we are going to
mark e  he step gay
[Music]
usually my life starts at 4 in
the morning since I got up you can do
my oral hygiene at 0 normal and then
I start walking around all the
facilities
and the first thing I receive are complaints that
today I already cuba  she is on a phone today to
cuba looking what year she has a pain we
need to see if you help us with
medication seeing that she would be my
mother with her white coat and jokingly she is
so elegant that one day I am
old for her I want to be a doctor she  I always
took the stethoscope I said when you
have this you don't know what weighs the
responsibility that you carry now that I am
a doctor of account that if it is a
tremendous weight what we carry in our
town
a moment please
I think that the leader does not decide to be  leader
if he does not become a leader after the
riots that occurred in immigration and
foreigners that closed there was no
way to do any paperwork what is
the acumar entity was already
[Music]
resolving the decisions  visions and everything
was negative so the only way
we had was to form a caravan that
the first
[Music]
you are fine here they have told you
point
how many ministers here or those who decide
they have
the ballot right now only Christmas
what had the energy
[  Music] well,
I lost my husband three years ago
in which he was provoked,
so we made the decision to come
unknown because the situation in the country
is too difficult, the work is useful to us, it
was the president, he shows off everything, he understands me,
and he receives less  day two they are
my daughters
because for others my niece and nephew are in my sister-in-law
they are my
family
with them I come and they
understand because as you can see I bring my
two babies most of them die as here they
are in babies and you can accommodate us in  the
ground we slept on the ground all the
time for a
long time enduring hunger the children
a very difficult point
the destination is none other than to reach the usa
well in the case of mine  family
we would go to texas
[Music]
and
but they are already organized and
could say that there are more than 1,000
who come there for this job because I
think they should already be around here
I don't think that in  tecún umán in tecún
umán which is the border there they meet in
the park they already agree
to enter mexico
[Music]
before everything when I met
her she worked in a tortilla shop
selling tortillas
I got there
that  place in the premises there it was there he sold
beer and all that I started to work
he came to play cards from there suddenly
playing well and that's where I started
and that's where we started like that well the truth was
with a cousin I had and I told her
dammit
help me with that war  she
likes her in bed and that's where we started once I told her I
wanted her for sale we were going to see them but not even
her mom her mom didn't know
her name is camila gesell medina
varela she
's 8 months old
his name is him and eduardo medina vale
has her
and  he has three  he is going to be three
years old, it is not hard because it is not
easy to say that it is already the corner, not
because the tiredness for one and also
for the children they get too tired because of
the heat,
we had not brought clothes but for the
reason that we are very tired  the clothes
that the few of us put on we have left,
I have will be endowed with the same and right
now
we are once again not even money money
we attract so that nothing
the children to say are a little dirty
because they do not have clothes you know something about
rags well
the truth is that  Well, I don't know if it's good.
I hope from what they say in the news
that with the Hondurans, it's kind of bad
[Applause] Our
goal, first of all, God, is to
reach the United States
for us, but for our children,
since they no longer use them, we want work
that they give us the opportunity if it is
possible, well, I say that for houston tex
and there
what he wants is that they support me and have
a job with which
my children can get ahead, well whoever is
needed  sario and it also depends on
the type of work think well
because whatever is necessary
[Music]
there
are already two girls left so we have
to disqualify a boy see
what's up, simpler of
course
[Applause]
if you believe  that the strong girls are going to leave
the applause for the girls
who says you don't want the visa
[Laughter]
poor girl my deepest
condolences count the steps for the
winner of
what I liked maybe they brought you
something to cheer up  the children of
activity and what I also liked because
they gave you something so that you live in the
place
and who does not like the chemical
that there is no light and that there is no water when
there is light
I can play for a while with my cell phone
dad half a bit because if it doesn't
discharge and I can charge it fine and
then when the electricity is on I can't
do anything anymore and you can't even play a
cache 5 in my house I can turn off the
lights it can be anything but in
other places it's not  because I don't know
not about me  apastepec I understand
that a pre-registration was made of the people of
the first 300 people who already had the
registration of more than 600 that was about
five days ago that they managed to contain
all of them and they all have the
registration and in less than five
days  they consider that they were going to the
man and tarja division, they are
waiting, they have not moved there because they are
waiting for them to deliver it and be able to
travel through it by plane or by bus
and no longer have to risk their lives while
walking, so this  I consider
that it was a promise in some way
because a commissioner from
the migration institute came and gave them this
news money money money gave me
other processes
[Music] it
is difficult to be explaining
to them they are hiring me to
assert their rights and  before the
constitution in our deadly country,
then I am going to process an amparo for you,
the federal judge is going to give me a
suspension that you can travel in the
country and have it for you  I have to respect my
nation
when we enter Mexico we go to
an institution called Omar, which
is there, they started
with paperwork to be able to legalize
the e-mails,
but right now they supposedly come to
inform them that well, we don't follow the
paperwork because at that time  They closed
immigration and they were going to open it in
three or six months. There are a lot of people who
are desperate,
they are waiting for a humanitarian visa
, but if it takes a long
time, this is going to explode and everyone is
going to leave in the caravan
up without  the need to wait
for women's roles
[Applause]
I don't understand anything else
many women talk about tomorrow about
many men even though they may
look beefy as it may be they are
all getting sick we all
come from the caravan and it's not fair that
they have us as  turn on and off
[Music]
[Applause]
the rumors well I guessed  Stately the
rumors yesterday that they came to bring
one of the Cubans who was the one who had
supposedly organized the caravan and
supposedly migration came, set him up in the
truck, put a green shirt on him,
I'm wearing him and we don't know anything more about him
at the century immigration station  21 is
that like all those who are going to
insure them, they usually send us
there, so there I understand that
mike is there and because of his situation,
I don't think they are going to repatriate him
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
when we're arriving
but if they listen if they were supposed to
be in Tapachula they
were supposed to start up here but in
fact we don't have the time or when it's going to
get here
and if the caravan manages to come here it's
going to be even worse
[Music  ]
[Music]
today we have walked from 5 in the
morning until right now at 4 or 5 in the
afternoon because the most difficult thing of all is
that good all of us who came
practically nobody helped everyone comes  they were
tired with
hunger most of the people who gave water and
all that is appreciated
[Music] they
take quite tired
if it is possible
for it to be necessary
still that is the beginning
the old ones no good a little scared
by what they had found out about  that
we say that no one can have it no
one can have it because none of us have been
relaxing or anything that is what we
come in peace we do not come to
harm anyone we simply want to cross
this
as I say when lightning strikes there is no
going back I don't  i repent because i
have a goal and that is the one i am going to
accomplish
[Music]
of glory horacio diaz god is
speaking right now i must read their
words that god is looking for
the sinner
the coffee that i have sinned buy in
let the powerful man leave us ma'am i
put it in your hands lord what is known
the need my god bless them lord
in the name of jesus our father in
the name of jesus lord I put it in
your hands  blessed god eternal father
look at his life lord here he is
eternal father give him your presence lord for your
glory father glorious brother father I
commend that of this girl lord no one
of this woman my god that on bund in
father will arrive with good the lord of
strength eternal father  For that crossing,
Mr. Gebas, who carried it eternal father,
so I do not commend it, blessed
God,
because they did not solve anything, they said
that we had no permission for more than
three months and people are not
willing to continue putting up with this,
no one is going to expect anything more from
us  we are going to meet here and there and
with the caravan that is coming
we are in nothing
but I do not want to continue risking my
family more on the walk because my
wife spent too much when
we were walking they made me sick and
I think I will stop unless I get
some money to continue, yes, but the
way it is right now, I think it
wouldn't be very risky for
all of us
if I was allowed to get to the United
States and and  or I will go where in the US
new york to
work study and have my money
[Music]
latorre I imagine him big pretty with
elevators with big offices
big employees and big ones
in fact as long as that has no life there
is nothing impossible and he should always try
If you want to meet your goals, you must not
give up. You always have to move
forward. It
is the possible micro
[Music]
that would be 160
United States
[Music]
smile hs h